salut tout le monde on va faire un point
sur le prochain top 3 de la draft NBA
c'est dans un peu plus de trois mois et
qui sera sélectionné tout en haut à part
l'inévitable Victor one byama c'est
notre podcast mensuel Victor et les
autres podcast de début mars c'est parti
le père et Hugo il prenne la Victor ce
fils dont le destin d'effraya les
gazettes
première partie on va revenir assez vite
sur le dernier mois de Victor one bagnat
ses performant ce qu'on a pu retirer du
visionnage de ces matchs et puis
deuxième partie un peu plus longue que
d'habitude on va évoquer les favoris des
outsiders au podium cette grave 2023 il
y a un numéro 2 assez clair qui se
dessine mais alors pour la troisième
place pas mal de suspens on va vous
faire découvrir les noms si vous si vous
n'en avez jamais entendu parler
et la paix en partie on parle de Victor
avec Hugues on a ensuite Thomas qui va
nous rejoindre ça va mon Hugues bah
écoute ça va tranquille tranquille ça
fait plaisir de faire un truc ensemble
de retrouver la famille c'est ça on
refait chauffer tout doucement le moteur
avec la draft qui approche avec la
marche maness qui va commencer là côté
NCA mais on commence comme d'habitude
par Victor web benyama
Victor tu l'as vu jouer ce dernier mois
qu'est-ce que tu as pu en retirer ce que
tu as appris des choses nouvelles en
fait puisqu'on a l'impression de le voir
tellement jouer est-ce que tu qu'est-ce
que tu as retiré de ces visionnages
donc ouais déjà vu j'ai vu ce dernier
mois c'est mieux c'est mieux pour en
parler
j'ai bien aimé notamment dans les
derniers matchs le fait qu'il
quand ce qui fait une première mi-temps
un peu moyenne soit par des problèmes de
photos par des problèmes d'efficacité il
arrive à bien venir en deuxième mi-temps
c'est quelque chose que
j'attendais un petit peu j'avais vu pas
mal de match en début d'année où il se
corrait beaucoup dans un moment où le
match était un peu un peu terminé tu
vois j'avais l'impression qu'ils disait
bon bah on est à plus 15 tous les
ballons ils passent la victoire pour
gonfler les statistiques et garder une
belle ligne à 22 points là je l'ai
trouvé plus décisif
je l'ai pas trouvé frustré tu vois quand
il manquait ses tirs j'ai vu un jour
plus patient qui gagnait au maturité
donc j'aime bien ce
ce développement qui est pas qui est pas
flashy qui est pas statistique mais qui
qui montre un mindset d'un joueur qui
qui est là quand même pour gagner des
matchs alors que on sait que on est sur
un objectif de vendre un prospect aux
États-Unis mais lui il veut quand même
essayer des matchs et sans plus
là-dedans donc ça j'aime bien ouais on a
vu des matchs avec les Metz et on a vu
aussi des matchs avec l'équipe de France
au mois de février c'est vrai qu'on
s'attarde plus trop enfin en tout cas
moi sur les statistiques à part les
seuls trucs que je regarde à la limite
ça va être ballon perdu et l'adresse au
lancer franc et alors l'adresse selon
ses France quand même la vraie bonne
nouvelle c'est que plus on avance dans
la saison plus elle est régulière vers
le haut quoi et donc ça c'est un vrai
une vraie un vrai indice d'adresse
future même si on parlera plus
profondément du tir
dans le prochain épisode on va on va
vraiment disséquer le tir les tirs de
Wemba nyama
on a déjà eu ce débat mais c'est vrai
que bon c'est pas revenu sur la table il
est pas forcément sorti pour blessure ou
quoi que ce soit c'est quoi ta position
à toi sur est-ce qu'il doit est-ce qu'il
doit continuer à jouer alors qu'il est
sûr d'être numéro un draft quel comment
on trouve la balance entre prendre de
l'expérience prendre du coffre aussi
enchaîner les matchs ce qu'il a quand
même pas beaucoup fait dans sa carrière
et d'un autre côté bah évitez la
blessure qui pourrait lui faire tout
perdre avant de signer son contrat à des
millions quoi
extérieur observateur tu as envie de
voir le joueur jouer mais on voit de
plus en plus de mecs qui se mettent au
repos pour sécuriser une saison
j'ai quand même l'impression que du côté
des Metz vu que le coach c'est Vincent
Collet coach de l'équipe de France j'ai
du mal à voir un joueur qui même en
accord avec un staff qui fait qui fait
une croix sur la fin de saison
parce que ça pourrait te mettre en
porte-à-faux avec ton sélectionneur de
l'équipe nationale et on sait que Victor
il a des ambitions nationales mais déjà
au prochain Jeux Olympiques donc voilà
juste pour une question de Sablé était
peut-être un club déjà hors français et
un club avec un un chef un coach qui
n'était pas Vincent Collet j'aurais pu
plus l'envisager là le fait que ce soit
son sélectionneur d'équipe nationale
j'ai quand même envie de me dire que ça
la foutrait mal derrière pour pour
porter le maillot des Bleus oui ça ça le
fait qu'il veuille jouer je pense qu'il
y a pas trop de débats il a dit qu'il
voulait jouer cet été d'ailleurs avec
l'équipe de
simplement
toi est-ce que tu penses que c'est
est-ce que c'est plus risqué que de que
de rien faire oui dans la réponse est
plutôt oui mais
est-ce que tu as l'impression que
qui prend trop de risques et ce que tu
as parfois tu as peur quand tu regardes
des matchs
souvent cette question de savoir si je
le mettais un ou pas parce que j'avais
peur des blessures c'est un profil
physique qui me faisait assez flipper
qui a déjà un gros passif
donc je serai proche du joueur je dirais
effectivement de de se préserver sachant
que beaucoup de mecs en université parce
que c'est eux la concurrence à côté vont
être mis au repos d'ici deux semaines
trois semaines si ce n'est qu'ils sont
déjà en vacances donc en termes de de
fraîcheur dans les esprits il sera pas
il sera pas plein de recettes les
joueurs de NBA c'est le moment où on
s'intéresse un peu plus à eux qui monte
dans les dans les cotes les jours de NCN
non Stanis a pris une grosse concurrence
non plus en d'autres ligues comme la NBA
et il a tellement d'avance il a
tellement pris d'avance que même au lieu
des des Américains et à ce que je
comprends de des franchises vu que
maintenant dans tous les matchs que tu
regardes les commentateurs des équipes
ne parlent que de one banyama alors que
il savait pas qui c'était il y a encore
un an et demi deux ans pour pour les
équipes NBA que honnêtement il
s'arrêterait là ce soir et on lui dirait
ben tu es quand même numéro un on se
rappelle qu'un mec comme ça il a pas
joué de la saison dans une autre draft
il a été quand même été numéro 2 donc
voilà il y a il y a des précédents oui
c'est clair qu'il y a des précédents
chez Eden sharp l'année dernière
drafté numéro 7 même si évidemment on
attend un futur beaucoup plus radieux
que que ces deux joueurs là pour pour
Victor one by nyama
on va passer à la P2
partie 2 avec Thomas qui nous rejoint
comment vas-tu
bonsoir bonsoir très bien comme
d'habitude très heureux d'être là en
plus on va parler beaucoup de joueurs
différents aujourd'hui donc c'est ça
particulièrement avec cet épisode pour
vous dire c'est ça puisque en plus le
premier big board en virgule le premier
mode draft vous dites comme vous voulez
écoute nous on appelle ça un big board
c'est sorti voilà on l'a publié sur
notre site envergure.co vous pouvez
aller jeter un coup d'oeil en guise de
référence sur ce qui va se passer
maintenant puisqu'on va parler du podium
de cette draft 2023 du potentiel podium
bon Victor web baniament 1 on l'a déjà
dit plusieurs fois dans plusieurs
podcasts et Hugues viennent de le redire
ça paraît acté maintenant on a beaucoup
parlé de scout Anderson joueur de la
jillig night pour être le candidat
naturel et même
indétrônable presque en numéro 2 est-ce
que c'est ce que vous pensez l'un comme
l'autre est-ce que ce scout and erson et
un cran au-dessus du lot pour vous en
numéro 2 je commence par toi Thomas et
tu peux juste redécrire vite fait qui
est scout
personnellement oui je l'ai tout seul en
deux j'ai Victoria banyama dans son
propre retiran 1 et j'ai scout Anderson
dans son propre tir en deux également
qui est scout Anderson rapidement c'est
un meneur de jeu de taille à ses
moyennes il doit faire un mètre 90
environ très explosifs vers le cercle à
l'âge beaucoup de dunk il a beaucoup
amélioré également son playmaking cette
saison je ne mi de range également très
très intéressant au vu de ses qualités
athlétiques
océan bonjour de Drive ou bonjour beer
range bon passeur un trois points et cas
continuez de progresser cette année donc
un joueur qui est amené à être le meneur
d'une franchise NBA et elle se portera
de balles primaire on l'espère
et je te laisse réfléchir à une
comparaison puisqu'on va rentrer dans la
période des comparaisons donc si tu as
des si tu as des idées de comparaison de
potentiel pour ce scoot Anderson
évidemment il sera pas il sera pas la
comparaison en année un Hugues quant à
toi est-ce que scooter est numéro 2 au
dessus des autres au niveau des autres
pas loin de Victor loin de Victor
bien au-delà enfin bien devant les les
copains en 3 4 5 etc
plus proche de Victor que je pense la
plupart des camarades et la plupart des
des scouts en global en tout cas pour
les scouts Twitter non on en fait partie
agneau amateur c'est un garçon que que
j'aimais beaucoup qui m'a déjà
régalé au niveau visuel et au niveau de
son jeu l'an dernier alors qu'il avait
un an de moins que tout le monde en Nick
night tu veux regarder Knight parce que
de base
et d'autres joueurs qui petite valeur
NBA finalement tu regardais que scooter
Anderson donc c'est un garçon
effectivement spectaculaire mais qui a
beaucoup de technicité dans son jeu et
je trouve que les progrès entre la
première année la deuxième année sont
déjà assez assez flagrant et il y a des
critiques qui sont faites sur son basket
donc peut-être on va parler un petit peu
après qui je trouve sont parfois assez
injustifiés j'ai l'impression qu'il en a
encore bien sous le coup dès qu'ils
montrent ce qu'il a envie de montrer
aussi il joue peu hein pour l'instant
cette année
assez peu c'est que quel cri de quelle
critique tu parles pas mal sur le tir
extérieur notamment quand tu regardes
les matchs il y a beaucoup de de
d'équipe qui le laisse tirer à trois
points qui passent qui passe en dessous
il y a beaucoup de commentateurs qui
disent ouais faut le laisser tirer à
trois points et moi je trouve que
systématiquement quand les défenses
elles font ça en face de lui alors on
parle de défense de jillig donc c'est
pas non plus envie de faire un blasphème
mais
il est efficace il podcast dans le dans
le pull up sur pick and roll quand la
défense passe sous l'écran il y a assez
peu de catch and shoot mais moi j'aime
beaucoup ce tir et effectivement la
mécanique elle est pas c'est pas un bel
arrondi mais on accorde de moins en
moins d'importance je trouve à la
mécanique quand l'efficacité est là il a
un tirage assez plat mais très en
efficacité donc je crois totalement au
scooter un Dossen scorer aux trois
niveaux ok
Thomas vous parliez c'est peut-être un
peu flou pour pour des personnes qui
débarquent dans le processus de draft
vous parliez de voilà des des tiers des
tu disais Victor dans son propre tiers
ensuite scout dans le propre tiers et
ensuite les autres
ça veut dire quoi c'est c'est comment
comment tu les tu les fais c'est c'est
groupe de joueurs comment ça fonctionne
et du coup scout il est dans quel groupe
pourquoi il est tout seul dans son
groupe c'est que ça veut dire quoi ce
groupe c'est quoi c'est les futurs All
Star S c'est futur c'est quoi
personnellement je donne pas de
définition précise à métier car je pense
que je pense que déjà peuvent être dans
le même tir sans avoir la même
projection en termes de plafond par
exemple je pense que les tiers donc ça
fonctionne aussi forcément avec le
plafond avec la probabilité qu'on donne
à ce plafond c'est pour ça qu'on peut
avoir un joueur au plancher un plafond
un peu plus faible il veut se retrouver
avec un joueur qu'un plan à fond plus
haut plancher plus bas donc c'est pour
ça que j'aime pas donner de définition
précises à matière car je trouve que ça
peut restreindre un peu ce que je pense
du coup pour moi les tirs en fait c'est
juste comment je classe mes prospects
quelle séparation je mets entre eux pour
moi il y a Victor en haut qui est
vraiment pour moi le numéro etc ensuite
j'ai scout Anderson qui est clairement
le numéro 2 et ensuite en 3 4 5 etc je
vais pas donner mes autres tirs pour
l'instant on peut avoir des des joueurs
qui sont assez close dans mon dans mon
esprit tout simplement sur lesquels j'ai
accorde une valeur assez
aussi proche en sorte en fait tu as plus
un groupe à partir de numéro 3 ensuite
un groupe à partir je dis une connerie
hein de numéro 8 9 etc
ça veut dire quoi rapidement c'est les
tiers dont tu parles est-ce que toi tu
donnes des noms est-ce que tu pour
t'aider dans ta classification mentale
est-ce que tu dis bah voilà lui c'est un
peu de temps ciel de
gamechanger donc il va changer une
franchise sur plusieurs années lui c'est
juste un potentiel one shot All Star
comment tu fais ouais il y a un peu plus
de ça chez moi
en gros si j'essaie de me projeter je me
dis ah ouais ce mec là effectivement
est-ce que je reconstruis une équipe
quel projection quel plafond il va avoir
et il y a aussi la la valeur du joueur
en tant que vraiment en tant que pièce
marchande et en tant que réflexion
peu importe mon projet il va tout en
haut et si je dois transférer tout le
monde parce que ça en fait embouteillage
bah je transfère tout le monde et je
m'en fiche ça coûte une personne ça peut
prêt à la même chose un petit peu moins
je vais peut-être un peu plus regarder
mon projet sportif et
écouter peut-être un peu plus d'offres
de l'extérieur je peux peut-être
envisager
un énorme transfert si possible et à
partir du du tiers suivant
clairement bah déjà je vais regarder
entre plusieurs joueurs je vais avoir
des discussions je vais analyser mon
effectif mon projet qu'est-ce que je
peux faire avec et les offres marchandes
ça me permet de classer les potentiels
de classer le projection et puis de
donner aussi une valeur voilà une comme
je l'ai dit une valeur marcher il faut
pas oublier que c'est que c'est aussi la
façon en tout cas de de raisonner
pour rester cartésien on peut aussi
raisonner comme un GM en se disant que
une draft c'est l'acquisition de valeur
de manière gratuite quoi en gros pour
une franchise
Thomas numéro 3
qui est ton favori pour pour être le
numéro 3 et je parle de je parle pas de
ton favori qui tu penses va être numéro
3 parce qu'on sait même pas qui va
drafter en 3 mais mais voilà et je
rappelle aussi l'importance en fait
pourquoi on fait le podium ce soir
l'important si tu es le plus mauvais
bilan de la Ligue au pire tu as le pic 3
donc c'est un pic qui est assez qui est
assez regardé en termes de potentiel et
qui va aussi influer sur la course au
tanking parce que parce que une équipe
qui voit qu'il y a un top 3 hyper fort
elle se dit bon bah au pire quoi je
chope un mec qui va quand même changer
ma franchise alors que s'il y a juste un
top 2 d'un coup tu as quand même une
chance de passer à côté
donc ton ton favori favorite top 3 et
puis dis-moi c'est c'est moi une petite
description de ce joueur
donc moi mon favori au top 3 donc sur
mon petit Barty vient de changer c'est
amen Thompson pourquoi c'est mon favori
le prospect de Lover tamily qui vient de
finir leur play off il y a maintenant
deux trois jours ils ont fait leur 3
derniers matchs des vrais bons matchs la
meilleure adversité qu'ils ont rencontré
en over time 8 points d'écart sur 3
matchs trois machines sur deux game
winner donc vraiment dommage très
intéressant à suivre pour le
réévaluation pourquoi c'est amen
Thompson mon numéro 3 pour le décrire un
peu c'est un meneur de jeu de 2 mètres 1
c'est un athlète j'ai j'ai pas les mots
pour le décrire ça n'a peut-être
absolument terrifiant il vit en NBA
demain c'est un des coups peut-être 3 5
meilleurs athlètes NBA il a un premier
pas juste sensationnel il a une manière
de se contorsionner est né dans les
espaces en l'air qui est juste à
s'incroyable une détente une détente de
l'espace également donc c'est vraiment
un athlète complet qui est juste qui est
juste assez irréel tout simplement j'ai
du mal à comprendre comment on peut être
aussi athlétique aussi rapide aussi
explosif pourquoi c'est
c'est mon numéro 3 car c'est tout
simplement je pense le meilleur athlète
de la draft c'est aussi potentiellement
le meilleur passeur donc il commence en
magasinier beaucoup de qualité c'est un
passeur assez impressionnant qui est
capable de pas ce que quasiment personne
peut faire en fait amène Thomson fait
des actions que ce soit sur ses passes
que ce soit sur son candle ses qualités
athlétique que je ne vois personne faire
que ce soit en overtime en NCA ou même
en NBA il fait des choses que personne
ne sait faire au monde quasiment
franchement je vois personne faire ce
qu'il fait c'est ça qui m'impressionne
le plus chez lui il y a pas mal de
choses à on sait qui shoote pas voilà
c'est c'est quasiment un mouche shooter
on sait qu'il shoot pas je le draft pas
en projetant un tir je pense il mérite
ce spot 3 sans projeter un tir je pense
que son principal travail va pas être de
développer se shoot etc va être de Clean
les qualités qu'il existe déjà c'est lu
de Clean son Wonder hyper encore trop la
balle dans son dribble et encore trop de
passe imprécise alors que comme je vous
l'ai dit il est capable de passe très
très supérieur il a une qualité pour
pour faire des jump pass
manipulations visuelles pendant le saut
etc c'est vraiment très très
impressionnant par séquence avec ses
qualités athlétics ça lui offre des
possibilités assez infinies donc on est
sur un meneur slasher c'est finitions
également très irrégulière beaucoup trop
irrégulaire même alors que les flash
comme son jumeau au sars sont vraiment
très très impressionnant par séquence
genre de transition exceptionnelle
potentiel défensif incroyable également
l'irrégularité est encore présente dans
ce domaine mais quand quand il s'y met
sur sur le point of attack comme on dit
post 1 2 quasiment 3 c'est vraiment très
très impressionnant et que beaucoup de
monde donc c'est pour ça que c'est mon 3
je pense que ça peut être un Bollène
l'air primaire en NBA il a des qualités
de l'éthique assez réel c'est un super
passeur ça peut être un super défenseur
un super slasher le shoot peut continuer
de progression on a vu que son frère a
fait des vrais progrès cette saison donc
pour moi c'est mon pick 3 je pense que
il y a plus de discussion avec
les gens derrière il est pas dans son
propre tir comme Victor et comme scout
mais c'est mon pick 3 alors
d'aujourd'hui et je suis quasi certain
que ça le restera jusqu'au moment de la
draft ok à toi Hugues qui qui est-ce que
tu nous mets à cette position numéro 3
alors déjà pour être honnête avec tout
le monde sait que les jumeaux Thompson
c'est pas ma plus grosse spécialité donc
je vais les je vais les rattraper j'en
ai vu mais c'est pas ma plus grosse
spécialité donc tu veux dire que tu as
pas vu beaucoup de films encore ouais
c'est ça et puis des choses récentes en
plus j'ai regardé un peu plus l'année
dernière là du récent récent moi
donc je les ai mis si vous allez voir
sur mon bord en fait je les ai mis là où
il y a à peu près le consensus en gros
alors du coup Thomas est là actualisé
mais moi je voyage je les ai mis là il y
avait le consensus pour pour pas fausser
les bords et pour rester dans une
logique ou effectivement il y a des
choses que j'ai vu totalement d'accord
je suis vraiment dans un tir très serré
entre en gros mon 3 et mon et mon set
j'ai mis en trois aujourd'hui j'y Allen
vous fait non
d'Indiana ce qui je pense que je vais
être le seul un peu par monde
je le fais parce que je me dis que du
coup dans cette draft
en termes de il y a beaucoup de gros
potentiels mais je vois pas non plus un
joueur qui peut révolutionner une
franchise
appartient pas assez scooter une
personne et Janet fino c'est pour moi le
meilleur joueur
lieutenant pour un projet c'est un
projet jeune le joueur qui va te rendre
tout ton projet cohérent et qui va te
permettre de passer des étapes ou bien
l'année prochaine sur une autre draft de
peut-être avoir encore un gros talent et
de bonifier ce talents c'est ce mec là
que je compare beaucoup lors de la draft
à tares à les Burton
[Musique]
il ressemble à quoi ce
j HS j'ai HS c'est un men le jeu à
mettre 98 95 kg qui joue du coup Indiana
freshman qui
est un excellent passeur c'est pas des
pas super flashy donc effectivement
c'est pas du de passe ou le corps se
casse dans tous les sens quand même
Thomson mais c'est juste des passes tout
le temps propre dans le bon timing
manipulation visuelle capable de passer
à une main sur les deux mains capable de
créer une relance il te créer une
transition c'est un bon rebondeur parce
que il est très grand qu'il a une énorme
envergure donc c'est un jour qui va
vraiment te créer un jeu de transition
dans des équipes jeunes qui vont souvent
aller très très vite c'est hyper
intéressant c'est un gars dont
on questionnait la capacité à tirer
cette année même s'il y a de
irrégularité pardon notamment sur le sur
le pull-up c'est un joueur qui a été
très efficace sur des tirs qui a pris
beaucoup de
matchs compliqués dans des matchs serrés
donc moi je vois vraiment un gagnant
c'est ce joueur là il donne un autre
niveau à son pivot twicecton Davis qui
est même parfois considéré comme un
joueur NBA c'est dire à quel point ce
qui est fino fait un travail incroyable
et
défensivement une polyvalence à défendre
du coup trois postes aussi le point le
point un peu plus faible c'est pour le
coup les qualités athlétiques c'est pas
un joueur extrêmement rapide c'est pas
un joueur qui va pouvoir te monter
dessus nous la comparaison avec Ali
Burton un peu ça j'ai en fait je le
mixte entre Ali Burton et lonzoball
moins bon défensivement que l'on the
ball quand même moins à la base que l'on
the ball mes propres comme Ali Burton
propre et comme une efficacité dans le
tir comme aussi à liburton mais ce qu'on
a le même le même QI parce que Ali
Burton était était déjà avec déjà des
des grosses une grosse influence of the
ball surtout sur la défense lorsqu'il
était en NCA et puis il était aussi très
à droite mine de rien à trois points
ouais c'est un joueur qui avait plus de
catch and shoot parce qu'il jouait avec
what about qui maintenant est à Gonzaga
je crois et qui portait beaucoup de
ballons alimentaires il avait vraiment
un côté c'est un excellent patient mais
il savait très vite se mettre sur le
côté et un peu ce qu'il avait eu avec
diarrone Fox en début de carrière
Sacramento et faire du catch and shout
là où ce qui fino a plus le ballon en
main pour rendre Jackson Davis le ce que
je trouve intéressant dans le cul c'est
que je me dis que les matchs regardent
les matchs les matchs où ils scores pas
beaucoup où il est pas droit et ben il
fait quand même forcément quelque chose
de positif il donne
de très bonnes passes à ce qui fait des
vis il donne de très bonnes passes à
West Thompson il crée du mouvement par
son positionnement autour de la ligne à
trois points il se replace très très
vite et puis je te dis crée de la
transition il envoie des ballons pour
pour les copains à travers le terrain et
c'est quelque chose que je peux très
vite projeter une billet donc voilà
c'est pas un choix sexy c'est pas un
choix flashy et si on me dit qu'il y a
des bien plus gros talents je suis
totalement d'accord là-dessus je suis
sur une logique vraiment de de projet
donc voilà mais je suis je suis allé de
toute façon dans ce range là je vais
choper un lieutenant donc autant
m'assurer d'un gars qui sera pour sûr un
bon lieutenant quoi c'est ça c'est ça
pour moi c'est une draft à deux jours
devant et donc derrière
je veux pas j'ai pas enfin je peux faire
un pari mais si je veux me projeter sur
plusieurs années j'ai ce mec là où j'ai
d'autres gars on va peut-être parler des
jeey West Walker des choses comme ça qui
sont qui ont des bons un peu bon s
plancher qui ont quand même des gros
potentiels collectif alors
Thomas déjà je sais pas si tu l'as dit
Hugo dit en gros sont tiers 3 elle est
entre 3 et 7 c'est à dire qu'il y a les
4-5 joueurs qui peuvent prétendre
à la à être drafté en numéro 3 si lui
était GM
chez toi c'est combien de joueurs qui
qui se battent en duel
moi mon tir 3 après en duel j'ai pas
forcément jusqu'à là avec même dans mes
tiers j'ai un ordre plus ou moins établi
mais dans je pense que je vais avoir un
tiers un tiers qui va de 3 à 8 avec donc
amène Thomson Brandon Miller Camille
more Jarry Walker mix Miss je pense que
j'aurai un tiers pas un vrai une vraie
séparation entière 0.5 après derrière ok
avec le 9 jusqu'à jusqu'à perpète avoir
alors présente-nous un pour toi un autre
Sider un gars qui
parfois tu dis tiens que je le mettrais
bien numéro 3 quand même
parce que tel ou telle raison qui est
ton outsider pour le le place sur le
podium de la draft 203
je pense qu'au-delà de mon d'un de mes
autres Sider on peut parler de Brandon
Miller c'est l'un des noms qui revient
désormais le plus souvent sur le spot 3
il arrive sur sur tous les gros Bordes
qu'on voit un peu un peu traîner à
droite à gauche sur tous les gros sites
il y a un peu de bataille entre la même
Thomson et Brandon Miller pour ce spot 3
pourquoi Brandon Miller continue
d'impressionner au fil de la saison
personnellement j'étais pas le plus
chaud au début et je trouve qu'il a
vraiment vraiment bien progressé au fur
et à mesure de la saison donc c'est
vraiment très très positif notamment
dans ses qualités d'accès haussière dans
son Haendel dans ses qualités pour aller
finir à l'arceau c'est vraiment c'est un
grand ailier qui peut Haendel la balle
et qui shoote très fort pour pour
2m6 très fort shooter j'ai pas acheté
sous les yeux mais il a 40 et quelques
pour cent sur 7 8 tentatives par match
ça peut être pour le petit groupe le
premier joueur de NCA de plus de 2m6 à
mettre 103 pendant une saison il doit
lui en manquer 7 ou 8 arrêts et Alabama
devrait jouer encore pas mal de matchs
pour qu'ils les mettent donc grand qui
est très fort shooter ADN
à une vision que j'ai vraiment pas
inintéressante il est capable de flash
très supérieur à la passe c'est pas
encore très régulier passe des deux
mains pour un élite de mettre 9 qui de 2
mètres 6 pardon qui shootent aussi bien
c'est quand même pas commun vraiment des
bons flashs à la passe jamais également
beaucoup son plancher c'est un défenseur
je dirais avril donc ça lui permet en
fait je vois mal un monde dans lequel
Brandon Miller c'est pas un joueur qui
met 15 points de l'aile en NBA tout en
pas où vous remporter un peu la balle en
tant que que tertiary bowlender je
dirais ou au moins facilitateur de jeu
plus un bon rebonder plus un défenseur
honnête plus du potentiel à continuer de
travailler sur son bolending sur ses
qualités d'accès Auxerre donc je pense
que c'est un des joueurs qui allait plus
haut plancher de cette cuvée tout en
ayant un plafond vraiment intéressant
car genre de domaine cheat de 2m pardon
qui shootent aussi bien qui est un super
joueur demi de range en High School il a
un peu abandonné cette année au profit
du trois fois mais c'est un super
c'était vraiment super fort et donc il
arrive plutôt à aller au cirque il a un
toucher vraiment vraiment sympa je
trouve c'est un excellent tireur de
lancer donc il y a pas mal de points
pour que Brandon Miller et donc un super
plancher un plafond également vraiment
de plus en plus intéressant avec ses
qualités handball qui ont qui ont tout
simplement décuplés au fur et à mesure
de la saison je trouve donc pour moi
c'est un un pic très intéressant à faire
quasiment derrière scoot Anderson si il
finit trop je suis pas du tout étonné
pour moi c'est un des premiers joueurs
qui vient avec les jumeaux Thompson dans
string HUG il y a quelque chose à dire
ouais juste je rajoute parce que je suis
d'accord avec quasiment tout ce qui a
été dit pour le côté mi distance c'est
vrai que c'est un point important et ça
s'explique totalement par le fait que
son coach Nate haute à la mama se base
sur un modèle NBA et refuse le Miles
c'est clairement
assumer on va au Cercle on tire à trois
points le mi distance vous faites une
croix dessus donc le côté pull-up à la
Jason Tatum
il a pas le droit de le faire et c'est
possiblement quelque chose qu'on qu'on
verra cet été il faudra pas être si
surpris que ça
est-ce qu'on a une comparaison Thomas
pour lui
j'étais en train de penser pendant que
tu parlais je pensais à Gordon et Ward
mais il est plus grand quoi
il est plus grande j'avoue les
comparaisons c'est pas c'est pas mon
force c'est pas la chose à laquelle je
réfléchis le plus il a un peu de
il a aussi un côté un côté fausse
athlète quand on le regarde il est un
peu il va à son apport
c'est presque le truc le plus
impressionnant quand je le regarde c'est
que il
paraît rarement
pressé il sait où il va il sait ce qu'il
veut faire il est sous contrôle alors
c'est un vieux freshman par rapport aux
autres mais c'est quand même assez
impressionnant pour un premier année NCA
pour finir sur lui bah
s'il était en France il serait en prison
quand on dit en tout cas en préventive
non mais c'est difficile de pas en
parler quand même
c'est d'autant qu'en février vraiment ça
a fait les choux gras
et à raison pour le coup de la presse
locale
donc je résume très rapidement mais
Brandon Miller
c'est prouvé et la police l'a dit et lui
il a reconnu il a apporté une arme qui a
servi
à un crime et lui-même était présent à
ce moment-là il a apporté il a je crois
qu'il a dit que c'était il a pas reconnu
que c'était volonté
une arme ça c'était volontaire
d'apporter une arme on va dire
ça c'est ce qu'il a reconnu
made n'est pas poursuivi d'ailleurs il a
porté une arme à un de ses anciens
coéquipiers qui lui est poursuivi donc
pour meurtre puisque c'est un d'ailleurs
ce qu'on appelle chez nous un féminicide
je crois pas que c'est existe la
dénomination aux États-Unis mais c'est
un gars qui a tué sa petite amie un de
ses ex coéquipiers donc personnage qui a
déjà des casseroles on sait qu'aux
États-Unis ça n'empêche pas de faire une
carrière
et lui ça l'a pas perturbé sur le
terrain est-ce que c'est une bonne chose
est-ce que c'est une blague suivante
est-ce que c'est une bonne ou mauvaise
chose quand on pense à la mentalité du
bonhomme je sais pas j'ai du mal à le
dire voilà maintenant c'est le folklore
américain faut faire avec et nous ne
nous ne sommes pas ni juges ni
procureur donc on va se contenter de
vous dire ce qui s'est passé et pour
l'instant il s'est passé ça et pour
l'instant Brandon Miller et poursuivi
pour rien du tout il est entendu en tant
que témoin dans cette affaire enfin il a
été entendu en tant que témoin dans
cette affaire Hugues ton outsider
je vais je vais faire la parole du
peuple parce que c'est un joueur qu'on
aime beaucoup chez un vergure et dont on
a beaucoup parlé depuis la dernière
c'est kamoït more
le freshman de Vilanova qui a tout
défoncé avec l'équipe zone américaine
qu'on perd de notre ami
Anthony black avec ces jeunes requins
qui jouent donc Avila Nova dans une
équipe des wild Cats qui en galère cette
année
on est plus on est plus coacher par par
Jay white monecoché par kale Neptune et
il a la tête dans les dans les étoiles
notre ami quel début pour le moment et
ouais ça travaille des transitions un
petit peu tu vois
mais comme wit more alors il a commencé
la saison blessée une blessure au niveau
du pouce qui l'a qui l'a handicapé puis
il est revenu une montée en régime un
peu diesel on a un joueur très puissant
pour ceux qui le connaissent qu'ils le
connaissent pas on est un mec qui est à
2 m à nos C à 95 kg moi je serais pas
donné qu'il soit à plus de 100 km
maintenant vraiment
un bestiau qui domine des joueurs qui
ont 4-5 ans NCA ce qui est quand même un
marqueur assez intéressant très très
fort finisseur près du panier très
athlétique capable de de monter en
transition un tir extérieur qui était la
question qu'on est sorti du tournoi
jeune avec les États-Unis et on voit un
joueur qui a une qui a voulu montrer
cette année je pense qu'il avait un
pull-up avec beaucoup de dribbles
beaucoup trop de dribbles et des tirs
très compliqués une sélection vraiment
assez catastrophique mais lorsqu'il joue
sur des enjeux un peu plus simple en
catchan shoot une belle efficacité donc
ça nous permet quand même de projeter
cet éliée un peu un peu Hollande dans sa
dans sa finition on se rappelle que Isa
coco on aimait beaucoup qui était aussi
une grosse bête physique qui avait la
question du tir qu'un wit Mora rapporte
plus de garantie toujours secteur là
défensivement maintenant on a on a un
joueur qui est assez peu fait d'efforts
qui est assez perdu dans une équipe qui
pour le coup était tu réputée pour être
une une académie de basket et on a vu
peu de création sur le mi distance on
sait qu'on n'aime pas trop le mi
distance en NBA mais ça permet d'évaluer
la capacité d'un joueur à créer son
propre tir et pour le coup aucune
création collective donc on est sur on
est sur un projet très brut dans tous
les sens du terme mais le combo
qualitatif athlétique domination
physique capacité à être un enfer sur
tous les mismatch que ce soit sur des
plus petits en bas ou à l'extérieur sur
des plus grands et le développement du
tir en font un mec très très très
excitant et il a annoncé normalement top
5 dans la plupart la plupart des bords
et c'était avant le début de saison
c'était le jour NCA qui était le plus
attendu je crois
de cette année non ça dépend de quel
classement tu regardais il y avait il y
avait Lively Duke mais la plupart
c'était des grands quoi donc les grands
c'est toujours pareil ils glissent
pendant leur année fraîchement même si
ils font une bonne saison sauf si ils
font une très bonne saison effectivement
8 morts attendu au moins à minima comme
une grosse arme offensive est-ce que
vous avez vous nous avez cité vos autres
noms est-ce qu'il y a des noms qui sont
cités ailleurs et que vous vous
[Musique]
pourrez pas vous renier mais vous dites
ce serait pas une super idée en numéro 3
quoi est-ce qu'il y a des noms qui
approchent numéro 3 et sur lesquels vous
êtes moins chaud
je peux me lancer peut-être alors je
sais pas si je l'ai vu jusqu'à numéro 3
mais s'il y a un gros écart entre ce que
je vois et le et le reste Anthony black
on a déjà fait son animation dans un
portrait où je disais déjà à l'époque
que j'étais pas hyper chaud et j'ai pas
envie de tirer sur le pauvre Tony black
à outrance mais c'est un joueur qui est
parfois cité top 5 top 6 de draft donc
pourquoi pas top 3 vu que c'est le même
tiers en gros entre 3 et 7 et moi il est
pas du tout là-dedans non je l'ai pas
mis au premier tour pas par provocation
mais parce que je crois pas du tout dans
sa projection NBA mais ça montre à quel
point je suis je suis un peu en
désaccord là dessus et que je ne
comprends pas réellement l'excitation
Anthony black alors que de base je
l'aimais beaucoup ce joueur mais mais je
vois pas de projection NBA
non pas spécialement je vois des
j'essaie de penser au nom qui tournent
un peu à droite à gauche mais que ce
soit donc comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure amène Thomson Brandon Miller
occupe quand même peut-être 80% des 3e
spot je dirais voilà à la louche nous on
peut avoir un peu doser
ou un petit Nyx Smith qui pourrait qui
pourrait s'engouffrer là dedans ton ou
peut-être de grosses marches Mendes ou
dans notre conférence au moins donc tu
vas voir mais pas trop de noms qui me
choque on sait que
on sait que Alan
sous le manteau nous vend déjà reste
Walker comme son Dark Horse pour pour le
pick 3 déjà reste au cœur qui est plus
un poste 4 qui joue du côté de Houston
et qui effectivement a du film
relativement impressionnant dans une
équipe qui ira loin probablement leur
souhaite à la marche Manesse donc un des
prospects qui pourrait marquer des
points et qui joue beaucoup dans une
bonne équipe il y en a plusieurs des
comme ça d'ailleurs
et donc vas-y vas-y
tous dans le même tir et on est assez
unanime tu vois je regarde le Big board
à part Manu on l'a tous en gros
si tombe 3 4 5 tu vois je dis pas comme
Patrick c'était monté plus tard sur une
un gros flash mais
ce serait pas si déconnant parce que
comme tu dis profil athlétique fou il y
a un plancher en fait tu sais que ça va
marcher et le plafond comme c'est une
équipe comme tu l'as dit très
compétitive du Houston le plafond est
excitant donc si je t'arrête Walker et 3
de sa draft je suis pas je suis pas
outré et je peux même être assez excité
en fonction des équipes qui le prennent
en trois absolument en tout cas c'est un
joueur qui est déjà très mature et pour
finir là dessus je vous l'avais pas mise
dans les questions
en préparation mais c'est une question
qui revient souvent surtout quand la
draft s'approche comme ça
qu'est-ce que vous vous dites en général
sur cette draft en fait quel est le
niveau global moi on écrivant l'article
sur sur notre classement notre bigboard
qui est sur le site je me suis dit il y
a quand même un paquet de valeurs sûres
en tout cas qui semble sur est beaucoup
moins de Paris dans le Range on va dire
7 à 20 que d'habitude quoi j'ai
l'impression que c'est une draft qui va
fonctionner
moi personnellement je suis grave que
que j'aime beaucoup je trouve que dans
beaucoup de sens elle est vraiment
intéressante il y a le gros duo ou un
bannia manderson qu'on projette vraiment
comme des leaders d'équipe en NBA
ensuite je trouve que jusqu'au top 10 on
a vraiment beaucoup de joueurs à fort
potentiel et genre combien de parler
tiens-moi les jumeaux Brandon Miller
jerse Walker qui est très intéressant
déjà sur son plancher avec également du
je me perds un peu du jazz au cœur j'ai
dit jet Award si on était déjà
un peu descendu à cause de son année un
peu en dessous mais ensuite on a encore
comme tu l'as dit beaucoup de joueurs
très intéressants jusqu'en 20 on a du
crédity qui fait une énorme année à
Kansas on a du kaison voilà du côté de
Kentucky même si la joue plus depuis
deux trois matchs il devrait rejouer je
crois en toi de conférence et vraiment
très intéressant Tyler Hendrix
incroyable je trouve qu'on a une très
forte en haut une loterie
potentiellement très très talentueuse
beaucoup
[Musique]
énormément de mecs qui arrivent pas déjà
à voir un bon deuxième contrat et là il
y a beaucoup de joueurs tu me dis bah
ils vont faire 10 ans et je me dis oui
pas de souci je les vois bien pouvoir
faire 10 ans et donc ça montre la
qualité on a une très grosse un très
gros wagon devant effectivement je sais
pas s'il y a énormément de mecs qui vont
changer l'avenir de franchise mais c'est
une draft de vrai bon joueur
[Musique]
ouais c'est sûr
c'est ça donc pour pour vous reporter à
tous les noms qui ont été cités par
Thomas ou pour voir le bord de Hugues
qu'il vient de citer également
envergure.co c'est tout sur le site les
scouting reporte comment ça s'accumuler
ça va s'enrichir dans les semaines à
venir effectivement avec
l'approche de la loterie et puis du jour
de la draft messieurs merci beaucoup
merci à toi merci merci
à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
dans Victor et les autres c'était
l'épisode de début mars on se retrouve
dans un mois et on va commencer
également les les petits portraits de
joueurs pour que vous ayez un tableau
une galerie plutôt tout à fait tout à
fait adéquate afin d'entamer la la ligne
droite de la draft 2023 avec une idée un
peu précise de de ce qui de ce qui
s'annonce bisous tout le monde prenez
soin de vous à bientôt